so we're going to head straight to Clark
County election headquarters now that's
where our Vanessa Murphy is and just
behind her election officials are busy
tallying those votes but how late are
they going to stay Vanessa
as of a short while ago results or
in-person voting results from all
locations in Clark County we're in the
volunteers cheered when those last
volunteers arrived but I want to be
clear we will not hear all results from
Clark County this evening here's why the
votes tabulated here tonight are from
in-person voting and early voting
including mail ballots received before
tonight mail ballots dropped off today
and arriving up until Saturday if
postmarked by today will not be counted
this evening Clark County Registrar of
Voters Joe Gloria acknowledging there
have been some issues with voting
machines some observers not following
the rules law enforcement had to be
called but he insists that those issues
have been addressed earlier Democrats
filed a lawsuit to keep polls open but
Gloria says anyone in line by seven had
the chance to vote
may have taken a little bit longer for
them to get through the line but at
seven o'clock we put somebody at the end
of every line and all of those voters
had an opportunity to vote but we have
procedures in place for anything that
would be out of the ordinary so we'd be
prepared to respond but at this point we
don't have any issues
one of the challenges of the rain today
Gloria is saying this likely affected
turnout and also the timing for
materials arriving here since volunteers
had to drive on those slick roads some
people driving from Mesquite as far as
Mesquite now as for when they will call
it a nighter you can see the activity
has really slowed down again all results
in from Clark County those in-person
voting results so we may see the
volunteers going home soon reporting
live in North Las Vegas at Clark County
election headquarters Vanessa Murphy 8
News Now